une inflation à 4,9 % en septembre sur 1
an résultat les étudiants dont les
parents n'ont pas les moyens de payer
les études enchaîne les heures dans les
supermarchés ou les restaurants une
contrainte pour la majorité d'entre eux
une autonomie bienvenue pour d'autres
deux témoignages deux expériences
différentes à tour recueillies par Lucas
Chopin 13h h kit la fac de tour il
s'apprête à débuter une deuxième journée
je sors tout juste de cours et là je
vais filer au travail du coup je prends
à 13h30 du coup donc j'ai 30 minutes de
de battement entre les deux donc c'est
un peu le rush je suis prêt à aller
bosser ouais c'est un rythme à prendre
après donc c'est vrai Queau moment de la
rentrée c'est toujours un peu compliqué
de se mettre dans le rythme et de
retrouver ce rythme un peu soutenu quand
même à peine le temps de manger et
l'étudiant en 2e année de sociologie
file au drive piéton où il est salarié
en accord avec l'université et son
employeur ses plannings sont souples et
aménagés ces 30 heures de travail
hebdomadaire lui sont indispensables
pour vivre les aides de la CAF et son
salaire lui rapporte plus de 1500 € par
mois je suis totalement indépendant et
c'est très valorisant de se dire qu'on
bah que j'arrive à être indépendant à
mon âge quand même psychologiquement
physiquement aussi il y a une certaine
charge mais je suis plutôt chanceux
comme étudiant et franchement je suis
fier de bah de travailler de travailler
à côté de mes études voilà Sian s'estime
chanceux d'autres ont plus de mal à
concilier études et emploi johann a 23
ans il est étudiant en 3e année de
musicologie dans une grande précarité il
travaille depuis la classe de terminale
au détriment parfois de ses études la
créativité sature enfin même je parle
dans un domaine où créativité musicale
notamment je ne peux pas composer je
travaille mais je dépense tout je suis à
chaque fin du mois c'est même la galère
pour pour continuer ah le boulot c'est
une nécessité c'est c'est clairement pas
un choix les cas de H et de Johann ne
sont pas isolé selon l'Observatoire de
la vie étudiante près d'un jeune
Français sur deux travaille en parallèle
de ses études